[Music]
i've always been a person who's just
been attracted to hair
i like to sit and think and theorize on
how i can do something how i can
manifest these uh visions that i have
for braiding and how i can take
something that may seem like it's a line
drawing in my mind and apply that to
someone's scalp the passion for creating
the work has always propelled me
we are the only culture that has hair
that grows out of our head the way that
it does
anyone from the african diaspora is born
with this amazingly curly hair that can
be
shaped into a variety of different ways
of expression
my work is hoping to promote black
self-love and i want black people to
love themselves for how they naturally
appear and also to appreciate the
cultural practices such as braiding that
our ancestors have practiced for
centuries
[Applause]
[Music]
shiny crow is the person here before you
resident of chicago south side lifelong
hair braider a lover of black people and
hopefully a promoter of black unity
[Music]
i'm an interdisciplinary artist i use
braiding
fibers beading anything that i can
really get my hands on to
express my ideas
working with thousands of calorie shells
tens of thousands of pony beads right
now
i have the patience for that i like to
sit in silence and just kind of
be
i started to
do my own hair between the ages of like
10 and 11
and then i started to get clients
between the ages of 11 and 12.
hi i'm just gonna ring the doorbell
shoes off yes right this way dear
there are a lot of style motifs that i
use like i use a lot of zigzags and
spirals in my work
in this particular style i am doing
cornrows which means the braid will be
attached to the client's scalp
cornrows the name came from the
agricultural aspects of the work that
the slaves were doing so it might be
called cornrow in the u.s if you go to
the caribbean it might be called cane
rules
and then i knew i wanted to do something
a bit more
sculptural
and so i went ahead and made a gym bay
which is a west african drum out of some
materials that i had at home
i'm going to attach this to the top of
her head and i would cover all of the
structural foundation of course with the
braiding
your hair is so full and gorgeous oh
thanks so much you can't buy this
this is great but y'all can't get this
from the store
all right let's get you shampooed if you
follow me to the kitchen okay let's do
it
first i wash my clients hair with a
moisturizing shampoo
i want to make the hair feel soft and
supple the process of braiding is a
highly manipulative and i want to
promote like a glide with my finger
as much as possible
from there we moved back to the chair
i will apply conditioner evenly to each
section of their hair and comb out each
section for detangling i use a
wide tooth comb so that i can gently
work through the tangles
i put it in a loose twist or braid i let
the hair absorb all that the conditioner
has to give
and then i will rinse out all the
products
then i blow dry the hair
[Applause]
once the hair is all dry i take a
special oil blend that i make myself and
i just put a thin line of oil
the most essential part of the scallop
oiling is the massage
that helps to stimulate circulation
which stimulates growth
and it's also a part of my way of trying
to create a relaxing and gentle
experience for them so that's a nice
step that helps to foster that sort of
connection
black hair is a really strong cultural
bond i believe
throughout different regions of africa
there are like so many different
hairstyles that people wear to convey
certain things about us and our societal
position
depending on the style you wore it could
indicate which
religious sect you belonged to or your
role in terms of priest or priestess it
could also be part of the royal family
and you had to wear certain hairstyles
all of these different things they
connote something about your identity
the origin of braids is actually traced
back to the african continent
specifically in egyptian history
they would shave their heads bald
and then they would use the
shaved hair and create these amazing
wigs and oftentimes the wigs were
created by
braided hairstyles
black hair is controversial has been
controversial since the very beginning
one of the first things that slave
traders did was to cut the hair off to
erase the significance of the tribe that
you might have belonged to
and straightening the hair has been in
existence now since like the late 1800s
they started off straightening their
hair with irons and ironing boards
when you wear your hair in its natural
state it does not fit within the
dominant ideal of what beauty is
supposed to be
being a black person and not looking
put together can sometimes cause harm
to you
you kind of have all these different
assumptions projected onto you people
will tell you no you're you're not about
to go to a job interview with brains
like that or you're not about to go to a
job interview with your parents
you better get a weave or press that
[ __ ] yeah if my job is not to have
straight hair then
why is this impacting my my ability my
higher ability
during the civil rights movement and the
black power movement
black people
decided that they no longer wanted to
follow the dominant standard of beauty
and so they decided to just wear their
hair the way that it came out of their
head
more recently we've had something called
the natural hair movement which started
in the early 2000s and it's been a lot
of black women have been able to use
their hair as a means of you know
self-love as a means of self-acceptance
hair is a way that we show love for
ourselves and
each other
so i'm glad to see black people
be able to embrace styles that just use
their natural hair
so after i oil the model's hair i go
ahead and create the center part
once i've kind of separated her hair
into two sections i went ahead and
roughed out a circle that was about the
size of the base of the jinbei that i
made in order for it to be balanced has
to sit in the middle of her head
once i've established that center circle
i take that hair and i section it off
and then i went back to my center part
reference line to create the braid that
is in the center of her hair
i then begin to plot out the rest of the
part lines
parting is essential because the parts
are the spaces in between the braids
that actually define the pattern that
you're creating i'm trying my hardest to
get the line as straight as i can and
they're never perfect to me i don't know
what it is
and then i will begin the cornrow
portion
[Music]
as you go you alternate from side to
side adding and picking up hair as you
progress down the part line that you've
created
because i've done it for so long it's
become more of just like a natural
motion for me
because braiding usually takes a lot of
time you're spending hours of your time
hours of your day with your client and
so it's a time for you to
chat and connect sometimes i play some
music talk about our life
i often light candles and burn incense
altar mix or frankincense it signals to
people in a way that they're entering a
more sacred space
my experience growing up in the city of
chicago
has been very formative as anyone's
hometown is
chicago carries a stigma
especially now
one that has been earned um for violence
but my upbringing was totally opposite
of that
from the time i was an infant i was
totally immersed in a afrocentric
learning environment it's associated
with the institute for positive
education
i grew up surrounded by people who i saw
as my brothers and sisters the people
who were my peers
the adults around me were my mamas and
babas
it was a very strong community rooted in
the fact that we are people of african
descent
my friends and i we actually established
a artist collective
a collective of artists designers and
educators we did what we could to kind
of continue the legacy and environment
that we come from the ideas of
pan-africanism and togetherness among
black people
this piece is called suntrust
this is the headpiece that the egyptian
goddess het heru wears she usually
represents things that are related to
like
feminine beauty
kind of like joy
i wanted to take these finger waves
and elevate them to the the highest
possible depiction that i could which is
that of a saint and so i chose to do the
kind of flat uh sundisk kind of aura
solange and her team reached out to me
to recreate one for her saturday night
live performance in 2016. it took maybe
like 50 hours to complete just because
of the beating i was sitting in the
corner beating i was beating at her
rehearsals i was beating everywhere
this piece we may fight we may have our
struggles but above all and literally
above both of them there is love so
though we may
not see eye to eye sometimes as a people
we can all still at our core see each
other as brothers and sisters
these negative aspects of chicago life
especially southside life
sometimes do rear their ugly heads like
you know you may know someone who was a
victim of gun violence
but the community that i come from still
serves as like a full support system
that i exist in and thrive in today
[Music]
i want black people to be able to trust
each other
i want black people to be
healthy physically and mentally and i
want those things to be the foundation
for
great unity
[Music]
so
after i've created pretty much my entire
cornrow design i have a few braids that
actually end in a tail and what i want
to do with that tail is add beads to it
i take a tool that i call a beater i
apply the beads first to that and then i
thread the models loose braid through
the loop and then i'm able to push the
beads up
and then i take scissors and trim off
the additional hair
so i do this to the four braids that are
left out in this style
i would
then attach the
pre-braided jimbei headpiece
i would take
some hair thread and a curved needle and
i gently sew
the hair piece to the surrounding braids
to make sure that it is sturdy and
centered so that it's not adding any
additional stress onto the model's head
because it is heavy
now that i have attached my gym bay
piece which is the center piece of this
hairstyle i must do some finishing steps
i'm going to come through with a
setting foam it kind of sets that style
into your hair
i usually add a silk scarf to lay the
design down so that it dries in that
position
[Music]
once i feel that the braids are
sufficiently dry and set i will remove
the scarf
and reveal
the beautiful braid pattern beneath my
goodness
like i can't believe that this is
my head
like i feel like
a queen
the whole time that i'm braiding i'm
thinking
um damn i'm messing uh damn it's not
gonna come out right oh wow this isn't
gonna come out right
but then once i can see all of the
effort totally finished it's the finish
line that you've seen in your mind but
now it has been made manifest
and you can
see what you put into it and you can
just bask in the glory of the beauty you
created
[Music]
black people oftentimes refer to
their hair as their crown
if you ask you know western society
where's your soul people point to their
chest right it's in here but across a
lot of west africa you point to the head
as the space where the soul rests
it's the top it's the closest thing to
the divine that we get on this side of
heaven
the resurgence of braids among black
people for me has been great i'm glad to
see black people be able to love
themselves and to love the beauty in
their natural appearance
it's something that i received as a
child something that has given me a
vision to want to promote that and it's
something that i hope my work promotes
that we are stronger together and that
through unity we can do so much
you